what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview interview Studio at
Sundance 2024 I'm very excited about
this one I love this movie so much your
monster huge congratulations I was
absolutely delighted by this film thank
you thank you so much so before we
discuss your movie I got to let everyone
know out there we are very grateful to
filo for helping us get to Sundance to
support independent film making filo is
shattered ing barriers by putting the
green light power in the hands of
creators and fans if you want to learn
more about filo and their Community
check out their website
film. okay Kayla you're getting the
hardest question of the bunch today
terrified I'm giving it to you because
you're also the producer on the film I
fear people might not know what your
monster is just yet so can you give
everyone a brief description of your
film yes oh God I'm so embarrassed in
front of the cast um your monster is a
story about uh Laura played by Melissa
whose life falls apart and you know it's
a true story also
truish I'm gonna keep talking oh I'm
gonna get um her life falls apart she
comes home miserable and meets the
monster living in her closet and they
have a pretty fun love story it's about
falling in love with your rage brilliant
brilliant way to explore that um I have
another question for you because when I
was reading our uh press notes you
called yourself a creative producer
which makes me really happy cuz that's
what I studied specifically and I feel
like creative producers don't get the
same amount of respect as other types of
producers so what does it mean to you to
be a creative producer well you know
it's interesting on an indie film
creative producing plus boots on the
ground producing is kind of what you
have to do because everybody has to do
everything but in terms of how I would
Define my creative role on this I was
really in lock step with Caroline the
whole time so we got the green light for
the film after she had done the short
but she wrote a new version of the
feature so this is was brand new to her
her so I worked with her we discussed
every single word in that script
together till 3: in the morning for
months and then on set I was right by
her side and then in editing as well so
for me also it's like you know to be a
director and especially to make
something that's such a personal story
to her I just wanted to make sure she a
had emotional support and B had the
creative support of somebody reminding
her like let's stay on theme what are
you trying to say here and and making
sure that she felt as proud as she could
at the end of the day because I also
love own friends you know we have to
highlight Caroline for sure I just want
to follow up on one other thing just cuz
you were so heavily involved in the
script process what would you say is the
biggest difference between the first
draft of this script and what everyone's
going to see in the finished feature
first
draft let me think God there's been so
many drafts um well it it got
progressively more and more and more
romantic but the other thing was we it
took a little time to land on what Laura
did for a living Caroline it's it's
based a little bit on a true story in
terms of her auditioning for someone
that broke her heart um but that was for
a different kind of project so some the
reason we landed on musical theater is
because we had a really long talk about
where we when we were young women felt
like we saw women that were messy and
loud and big and were applauded for it
and musical theater is really that space
it's like Patty Leone is on stage
screaming and everyone gets up and
applauds that and so we wanted Laura to
get there and to have that experience oh
I love that element of the movie I can't
imagine the story any other way so like
I said we have to highlight Caroline who
can't be here today but for good reason
I was watching her uh meet the filmmaker
video it's because she's got to have a
baby and that's wonderful but we need to
celebrate how damn talented she is I'm
going to ask a whole bunch of questions
about this Tommy I'm going to come your
way first because you also worked on the
short how did the two of you first meet
and when you first met what was it about
her that signaled to you this isn't just
someone I want to work with once but
maybe have a longlasting creative
partnership with I met Caroline as an
actor she was doing two episodes of a
show um I did called casual and uh she's
a great actor she she won't admit that
but she's fantastic she's clearly very
smart we started talking about writing
and um but then went our separate ways
and then I want to say a year and a half
or so later I did the One Yoga class I
do every decade and she was there and
approached me afterwards and she's like
would you read this monster thing and
think about doing this and uh I mean
she's taken a leap of faith I've never
done anything with prosthetics anything
like but something about our experience
working together for those couple days
um I don't know made her think that I I
might be able to pull this off and um so
we did the short and then I don't it's
it feels like it was six years ago I
don't really know I've lost track of
time but um but I kind of tracked the
the development process with the with
the feature and um it's like this dream
story like it never happens but it
happened with us you know you make a
pitch perfect as Monster here my God I'm
going to come back to the Prosthetics
too uh Megan and uh edmin I want want to
throw another question about Caroline
your way what is something about her as
an actor's director that you really
appreciated and you look forward to more
actors getting to experience when they
work with her on the F in the
future um well I think the first thing
that comes to mind is I think that
Caroline just really loves actors and it
is true that she's a very good one
because I saw her in a short that she
did and it's so funny that she won't
accept that but that I think is probably
part of why she's so good with actors um
she knows how to talk to them and she's
genuinely excited by things that the
actors will come up with and she's like
ooh that that that yes do that again or
you know she's such a playful sort of
supportive open and excited person who's
really good at communicating so I feel
like as an actor what else could you
hope for when you're working with
someone you know does she have a monitor
dance like is there something she
does and it's true she she trusted all
of us and trusts actors so much there's
a lot in the movie that wasn't in the
script that we were just kind of playing
around and and and it ended up in the in
the movie and that's because she gave
kind of gave us the reins uh I had so
much fun making this movie and I credit
that entirely to Caroline yeah can you
give us an example of something that
wasn't in the
script um let's see
um a bunch of stuff in the fight that we
have on the stage right isn't that right
and then line we were talking about
yesterday yeah I'm blanking but there's
so many things you just yeah the New
York Times is in the audience that stuff
this is this is so awkward yeah
this is so awkward yeah this is so effed
up I say at one point yeah I mean there
there really are a lot of for all of us
I think things that we made up she does
this really fun thing where she'll just
yell from behind the camera wherever she
is say this yeah and then you just try
it so it's like she's very present and
then and as a result you feel very
pulled into the present moment as the
actor too so it creates this really cool
space it's a very rare quality for a
director and their debut feature to be
willing to sort of see where the day
takes you you know because it's like you
know I think there's a tendency to kind
of want of over contr control things but
she was really open to this all us actor
nerds just like you know taking big
swings she also just voice from the
editing room um she cares so much about
every person's performance and giving
giving the best version of that possible
of course keeping story in mind she goes
through every take every word every eye
every look to make sure that all of us
were telling the truth in the best way
possible she really really cares and she
loves these guys a lot and and when we
were shooting especially when like Tommy
and I were doing like the cuty stuff
together like it became a thing of we
wanted Caroline to come and like be very
excited and and dance and yell and she
would like like get on her knees and she
would fall on the ground when she when
it was like the right amount of like
mushy lovey like deliciousness that she
loves and so that was our goal we
weren't willing to move on unless we got
her swooning and then we like Mak happy
that she's so expressive about it I feel
like we all need to be more open with
how like exciting and fulfilling it can
be when you nail a scene Melissa I saved
you for last in terms of my questions
about working with Caroline here because
it was already brought up this is based
on a truish Story how does it change the
game for you when you're working with a
director with such a direct connection
to your character who's also willing to
be so open with you about her experience
and also the world too it was beautiful
it was beautiful
to to have a director that's that is so
specific about their vision of the movie
but also is willing to let you discover
things but is always beside you like
I've
always I've always wanted to work with a
director that you feel cuz I think
that's what makes great actors than
working a partnership with a great
director I actually think that's what
makes it that's what makes an actor
great and that's why you see so many of
the Great actors where they have like
these special connections with certain
directors that they always work with
because I think they have this thing
this communication and she was always I
always felt safe with her and I always
felt like she was beside me but not
dictating things just guiding me to
places that I didn't even know I was
capable of going and she was she knew
that I could get to these places I
didn't and I was scared I remember in
the like one of the first few days where
we were shooting that scene where I
first discover the monster and I'm on
the couch and I'm wailing and I was
crying and it's there's a lot of crying
in this movie and she was like I want it
I want more and I was like what do you
mean more like I don't I don't know what
you mean and I was like what what she
was like go like just I need you wailing
I needed to be loud and I was like that
feels I don't know that that's going to
feel real coming from me she was like it
will trust me just do it and that's how
we ended up with what you see in the
movie but but she was so sure that I
could get to that place and I wasn't but
it was because of her like telling me in
such a loving way and I just love for it
I think she's brilliant I think any
actor would be lucky to work with her
and yeah that's it we love her that's
making me think it it kind of leans
nicely into our filo question of the
festival because again they're all about
putting the power in the hands of the
creators whether it is on this film or
anything else you've all worked on can
you give me an example of a time when
someone gave you creative control maybe
even at a time when you knew you
deserved it but you didn't think you
were going to get it
this movie um our our team behind us the
rest of the producers gave Caroline and
I so much creative control it was it was
pretty unbelievable we would kind of I
mean even just saying okay we have an
indie budget we want to put a Broadway
show in it we want Prosthetics we want
to hire an Oscar winner to do it and
it's going to be a 20-day shoe you guys
good and everyone said yeah and everyone
did it and it was really ambitious and
it was really hard and the product is
really fun and I think that that's a
really rare thing and can I say the word
really any more times I'm fine with that
it applies you and I say this as an
actor you said it kind of differently
each time and so you kept it
fresh the voice of Caroline has Ren uh I
would add to that that like just in
terms of this movie I I was welcomed
into the design phase of the monster I
was going up to Dave Anderson's lab
which is the most fantastic Place
everyone should should be so lucky to
visit that place and um and go through
drafts of the monster um and so uh I
have no business doing that I don't you
know that's not my uh Forte but um but
man was at a a cool ride yeah also I
like this the process it was so quick
but we were hanging out a lot and we
would just kind of the
rehearsals were during the shoot and we
would just kind of like get together for
dinner and like run some things and
Caroline from the beginning with us it
was very cool cuz we would just get
together over order Chinese
and read through and then work it out
and change it in the moment and we'd be
and Kayla would be in the computer on
like final draft and we'd be and that's
how we like came up with a lot of like
the bantery things and a lot of like the
deep emotional beats and I remember I I
forget what scene it was um but I
remember Caroline had something and it
and I read it and I was like this feels
very right but I feel like I would say
it differently like my Laura would say
it differently to Caroline's Laura so I
took her things and I kind of did like a
little puzzle fight scene wasn't it that
it was our fight it was our fight at the
end which changed completely thousand
times when Melissa came in it was it
changed for me completely and I I had
been with the script for months and then
she came in and it changed it changed my
whole Arc of Maisie was Melissa talking
to us about her version of Laura it was
really cool yeah and yeah just the
openness of like allowing me as an actor
coming in to be like what do you think
of this cuz this feels like and this is
what your lines inspired and thought of
me so I want to add this like I actually
want to say this too and you know and
like just the the collaboration of it
all like the definition of collaboration
that's what it said literally what I was
going to respond to that um Edmond Megan
anything you want to add to that
question time when you got creative
control when you didn't expect it um
this morning when I added feta to my
avocado toast I thought wow what an
incredible option um no I don't really
have anything to add I mean a joke but a
but a good option to have yeah
creativity comes in a lot of different
forms yeah you did have some of it yeah
um I did a show called the bll type for
a while that I loved and that was
actually the first time I was on a set
where I felt like my ideas were being
taken into consider ation or if I wanted
to change something or whatever it felt
very collaborative in that way and so I
think that was probably my first
experience with
that yeah a project I worked on uh show
called Betty on HBO with Crystal mzelle
who I believe is an Alum of Sundance
incredible filmmaker and um she the
almost the I mean we had a script but
she really encouraged us to improvise
and it's challenging you know because
that's the role of the writer you know
creating that form that structure um but
it's freeing when it's done by the right
person and I felt that way with Crystal
and similarly with Caroline they're the
two people who I felt that way with um
yeah yeah this last question here might
be a weird question and it kind of puts
you on the spot creatively but it's
something that I found myself thinking a
lot about since watching the movie how
do you imagine your own monster might
manifest and look if that happened and
what might the monster teach
you well my monster would definitely be
as hot as
Melissa's let's get that
straight I don't think anyone's going to
top that answer now no I like that one
got to have a hot monster guys yeah I
think that's the reason that I don't do
aasa cuz I'm scared of that so I don't
know God I don't know having having as
the monster in this movie I have trouble
thinking of a monster that looks
different um but I think we could all
use a little help standing up for
ourselves you know i' I'd hope that my
monster would help me do that a little
more that's where my mind went the idea
of standing up for yourself but like in
a way of like fighting the urge to put
yourself down so I feel like my monster
would be like a Monster version of Me
Maybe my monster is Patty Leone I love
that can we get signed off on that
you're a producer is yeah I got you I
got
you anyone else have a monster idea
I mean I I've always love loved vampires
so I hope that my monster manifest is
like a hot Dracula I'll take that I'll
take that and uh while I wait for that
sequel I'll just rewatch your movie over
and over utterly delightful just like
truly a like a Pitch Perfect uh genre
mashup and I can't believe how well you
excelled at every single element you
included in this movie congratulations
so much thank you to everyone out there
thank you for watching St tuned we will
have more interviews from Sundance 2024
for you very
soon